but there is some news as the NFL moves
toward releasing this schedule we're not
mocking our friends we like it I like it
I prefer schedule I like the sound of it
I like saying it I don't like saying
schedule anymore schedule it now is any
way before we can get to that the league
is making plans for reopening the team's
facilities and it's a little confusing
to say the least the NFL sent out a memo
yesterday to all Club executives and
team presidents making sure that they
understand what is expected of them as
we move toward the possibility of
phasing back in the various team
facilities phase one is upon us we just
don't know when phase one will actually
commence by May 15 that's next Friday
teams have to be in position to
implement phase one
even though phase one won't necessarily
be implemented on May 15 that's where it
gets confusing to prepare for phase 1
where you're going to be allowed to have
roughly half of your workforce or up to
75 non player employees present on any
given day you have to obtain consent
from state and local government
officials there needs to be an infection
response team and infection control
officer these are folks are gonna be
responsible for making sure that anyone
who is sick they do contract our contact
tracing disinfecting of any areas of the
facility where the person who turns out
to be positive may have been making sure
there's someone that that anyone who
feels sick can go to that's what the
infection control officer will do so all
these plans have to be put in place
prison and where I got very confused the
idea that in phase one before you can
open you have to have consent from state
and local government officials it made
me think well wait a minute the NFL is
breaking from the rule that's been in
place for seven weeks now but if even
one facility can't open no one can open
my understanding is and the league is
clarified that that's still the case
that if even one facility can't open no
one's opening so I look at this I say
what the hell are they doing are they
confident that
every team is going to be allowed to
open its facility in every state where
the NFL does business at some point in
the next two weeks that's big news if
it's true otherwise everyone's wasting
their time because if only one team
can't open none of them will open Chris
well III think there must be something
there to them thinking that it's around
the corner to where they could get all
the facilities open for all 32 teams and
all the different states you know so I
think that's encouraging also you know
again you know we've had this
conversation many times these are thirty
two of the most powerful people in our
country I mean they're in that
conversation I think they probably know
things that we don't know anyways to
begin with and you know secondly
nonetheless whether it's open in two
weeks and they can do that on May 15th
or not to me it I don't care the good
thing is is I'm very encouraged by the
memo itself I mean the memo itself is
well thought out you can tell the NFL
has really put time and effort into this
to come up with a game plan and show
leadership to the rest of though the
work force whether it be the NFL PA or
front office people coaches GM's
whatever it may be to go know we're
gonna have protocol and guidelines here
and we do have something in place to
hopefully make this season work and you
know make it work to where people don't
have to feel like they're compromising
their health and and make them feel at
least as safe as possible in this
strange time and Chris beyond that other
industries small businesses that are
going to be reopening they can just take
that memo and I should post the whole
damn thing as a service right just that
memo and say we're gonna do these things
for our business well yes you know Mike
I mean yeah I mean the thing I got
excited about is I really got excited
about whoa like look at the leadership
here this is great this could be given
out to the whole country right now to
just say hey these are little guidelines
if you want to open your small business
or restaurants or whatever maybe these
are the things that we're gonna have to
start kind of you know messing around
with in our brain to figure out the
right formula to make all this work
and still state and local governments
are going to have final say and you
touched on the reality that these teams
are owned by people who are very rich
very powerful very knowledgeable and
there will be I believe some complicated
political negotiations as it relates to
getting the permissions necessary and
there will be a delicate PR situation
here as well Chris because if you do
have states and communities that that
aren't allowing business to operate and
I know the trend right now is to open
things up again and I'm not gonna go
down that political rabbit hole as to
whether or not it makes sense to do it
but if you do have locations that aren't
yet to that point but the NFL wants all
of its team's facilities to be open you
you do run the risk of a PR problem
where the NFL facility is the only
business in town that has the license to
open its doors when it's really not an
essential service obviously pharmacies
grocery stores have been operating
throughout this pandemic but there are
plenty of other businesses that would
love to operate and the NFL isn't
essential by any means that's where it
can become a little delicate and I think
that this political negotiation is at
some point going to butt up against the
PR reality of how's it gonna look if you
can't open up non-essential businesses
in a given state but the NFL teams that
play there get a free pass from the
governor well yeah that'll be that's a
dicey situation you know that is now you
know also I think you know a lot of
football teams might be able to claim
that they do a lot of good for the state
as far as employing employment taxes
whatever it may be that contribute to
the state's overall funds to where that
can be an argument but you're right it's
not gonna be perfect there's gonna be
people that look at it and go you know
this is unfair we're treating a very you
know high-end commodity like they're
special like they're more important than
the rest of us so yes I get that but if
we do and we're starting to see States
you know loosen up the guidelines a
little by little you know the other
thing that's awesome about this Mike is
you know again the NFL is laid
the groundwork to show the states a
little bit to go hey well will be the
first case experiment to say okay we're
not the essential working program but we
have guidelines in this memo which is
very impressive you know as far as what
what the the workers should do in the
facility how far they should stay away
from each other on a given day and how
many people were allowed in a certain
room in the facility all - all together
to begin with so all right when you see
those little things - I think the NFL
and their brass will be able to play hey
listen we'll be the guinea pig here and
you could see how we do things here and
hopefully it can set off a chain of
events to where all businesses can kind
of follow our lead and follow our model
and the key over the long haul is going
to be testing the availability of tests
and quick and easy and there continues
to be a leaf a belief that by the time
we get to August that testing will be
far far more prevalent than it is today
so this is just a way to kind of get
things going while we're waiting for the
testing to be much more easily available
back to the political reality of this
the negotiations that will happen in any
political negotiation or in any
negotiation whatsoever it's important to
have leverage and and this is a point
that I want to revisit just very briefly
we were spitballing yesterday about the
possibility that the schedule see I'm
already trying to make it stick we'll
have some clues that may show that if
for example California won't let the
charges the Rams and the 49ers play in
their stadiums or open their stadiums to
fans they could relocate those teams to
other NFL stadiums and then we would see
by the configuration of the games oh
look the Chargers and the Cardinals
never are at home on the same weekend
maybe they're thinking about putting the
LA Chargers in Arizona for the year if
they need to do it and our good friend
young MC texted me a thought on this and
this is where it gets into the political
realities of the situation having the
schedule set up that way Chris gives the
NFL leverage in the event that they do
get into a situation where they're
working through the political realities
with Gavin Newsom the governor of caliph
and if they don't like what Newsom is
saying the NFL can say fine we'll take
the Chargers to Arizona we'll take the
Rams to Las Vegas and we'll take the
49ers of the Colorado and we won't play
any games in your state this year that's
part of the and and look I understand
far bigger issues are going on but this
is to understand how the rabbit hole is
gonna work for the NFL and how deep it
goes it's part of what you have to have
in place in order to get what you want
and they're gonna be dealing with
governor's in 22 different states trying
to get what they want and what they want
is the ability to play those games so
you have to have some of these plans
baked into your own planning and by
virtue of how detailed this memo is it
makes me think there probably is a lot
more going on beneath the surface that
we don't know about and that we may
never know about that's aimed at helping
the NFL get to where it wants to be and
that is playing all 256 games yeah well
I know you and I both have talked to
people in the know right in the nose you
know that that led us to believe a few
weeks ago that the NFL had plenty of
contingency plans and that they were you
know working you know around the clock
to figure out how to make a season work
and and and and if it doesn't work one
way come up with a plan B and whatever
it may be now I don't think we're gonna
see that type of stuff on the schedule
of the night right I mean you're not
expecting like to see any of that
tonight we're gonna have a normal
schedule release tonight but there might
be some differences as far as how they
do it but you're not you're not expected
to see anything out of the normal as far
as the initial schedule early you are oh
I definitely am and there's already been
multiple different reports and I've been
hearing this for weeks now that all of
the inner conference games are going to
be in the first four weeks of the season
so if you have to wipe them out
you have 12 games left that are all
played in the same conference which
gives it a greater sense of fairness if
you're competing against teams from your
same conference to determine who makes
it to the postseason you can just cut
those four games off and maybe even tack
them back on to the end of the schedule
if you want to but you know that that's
that so I think there will be clues
Chris that are obvious and then there
will be clues that are potentially not
obvious so one of the reasons I'm
putting this out there is I want
somebody else to put in the elbow grease
and I'm
the emails and the DMS will be open yeah
bots some subtlety in the in the
schedule so we can say hey you know what
there is something here look that the
Chargers and the Cardinals never do play
at home the same weekend maybe one of
the contingency plans is taking the
Chargers to Arizona for this year's
games that'll be interesting to say that
really will be and that'll be something
I'm looking for now that you kind of put
it on my radar and you know you talk
about the inter conference games that
make sense that's something I thought
about you know that that certainly I
could see them grouping that together or
you know are we gonna have certain
weekend's of just like it's just
division games its division rivalry
weekend right I think you're gonna see
weekends of that to where it's gonna be
two teams in the AFC East like two teams
from the AFC East and so on and so on
right down the line just to make sure
we're not like like you said we miss a
week or something's got to get cut out
or whatever it may be and teams have
playing and uneven division or inter
conference games to where then it
affects tie breakers and things like
that the NFL is gonna have to be careful
of that so that is something that I'm
expecting to see on the schedule tonight
so but here's the other thing to keep in
mind if the NFL gets to the point where
weeks are canceled and not made up and
let's say there's 12 games let's say
there's 10 games right in 1982 the
strike-shortened season where nine games
were played what happened the lines of
the divisions went away and they took
eight teams from each conference I mean
in the first year that we are officially
going to have seven playoff teams per
conference there is a chance that the
NFL will lose enough games to share and
again I'm not saying it will happen but
we just have to put this on the radar
screen of possibilities there's a chance
that the NFL will have few enough games
played where it says we're going back to
1982 we're just gonna do an 8 team per
Conference tournament based upon seeding
without regard to what division you're
in which is exactly what they did back
in that strike shortened season where
Washington won the Super Bowl and and as
we said yesterday no one ever has
attacked no interest to it even though
the world got turned upside down at
least for the NFL that year one last
point before we break as it relates to
messages from the league office to the
teams and we saw this as it related to
the draft remember when the end
Phil said we're going forward with the
draft and it serves no purpose for
anyone to question it if you do you're
gonna be in trouble the NFL has said
something like that as it relates to the
plans for the 2020 season basically the
message is don't speculate
don't talk say anything about what you
think could happen we are planning to go
forward and any deviation of that comes
from us not from you any discussion
about what's going to happen comes from
us not from you and the NFL has already
managed to avoid speculating on anything
Chris no hypotheticals no what-ifs this
is what we plan to do and if and when
our plans change we will tell you that
fact yeah well it's the right thing to
say you're right I mean speculation is
only gonna make things more confusing
and harder for the NFL and just create
more issues so let any it's like us
speculate people that work for the NFL
keep it on the straight and narrow I
like where we're going I'm excited and
you know what I'm really also impressive
that picture with Roger Goodell there
look at he's got his top button button
look at that guy their top button swag
maybe he is my evil twin after all can
we put that back up because I think
that's an altered photo in some way I
don't I don't think I've ever seen Roger
Goodell with the top button swag was
that altered or not altered was it
altered that Kristen's talking to me it
obviously altered she said so I think I
think they they concocted that in the
control room just to make you feel
better about button in your top really
good and as we said to him in Santa
Clara you're the evil twin to him he's
not evil twin to you we just want to be
clear right yeah we should be very clear
we see the commissioner we're talking to
the commissioner and Kris makes sure he
says we've got this photo that we use of
me that we say I'm your evil twin and
he's funny he gets it he said wait who's
the evil twin me or you it was a really
good laugh and off we went right off we
go
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports